right now glenn thanks so much for
coming on what's your reaction to all
this
uh i i'm trying to take a bigger view
um and looking at you know none of us
were in the jury room
but now we're kind of in our living room
and we're all dealing with it together
and you have to ask
what's next and what role am i going to
play in that and
you know i saw nancy pelosi look to the
skies
and thank george floyd for giving his
life for for justice
um and that's one of the things i'm very
worried about
we don't in america try symbols
or movements we try individuals and like
i said i was not in the jury room
uh and i don't want to get into that
because that is our system
um but right we we have to try
individuals and not uh movements this
verdict does not bring george floyd back
to his family
this takes another man who got up one
day and wasn't thinking i'm gonna kill
somebody wait away from his family
perhaps for the rest of his life i i
wish today
we could be a little more like the amish
when uh the gunman came in and killed a
lot of their children
they mourned with their children but
they also went and they mourned
with the with the killer's family and
said
it wasn't you but that's not the message
we get from too many today
it's all about collective justice and
collective guilt
we need to mourn with both sides and
realize
this has been a horrible horrible year
that has torn our country apart and we
started
together when we all watched this that
first day
we all gasped we all said oh my gosh
we were united but then politics
slunk into the room uh and
and tore us apart for what
for what so what is it that we
we do now tonight a guy is
dead and another guy is going to jail
for perhaps the rest of his life
um and we're looking at a system where
justice should be blind i hope it was in
this case
it shouldn't be about color it shouldn't
be about wealth
or station it's blind justice not
social justice and then when we achieve
that we do the best we can
and only god can restore uh
everything else i i just tucker
i have so many emotions because i'm
watching
everybody react to this on tv
and i just think to myself uh
how do we turn this into a positive how
do we
can we come together with malice toward
none and charity toward all
and come together and and heal the
wounds
can we find principles that we have in
common again
i know everyone that i work with
everybody i know
is looking towards those principles of
equal justice and get the bad guy
not color not trying people
for a cause um we have a great
opportunity let's see if we
if we grasp it so nicely put
glenn beck thank you i appreciate it
thank you